(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
- All right, so I always try to close out
with something we hope
will make you smile.
Here's "What I'm Liking."
(upbeat music)
(audience cheering)
There are so many amazing
movies people watch every year.
One of my favorites that I
literally watch every year
with my kids is "The Sound of Music."
I love it so much.
Yeah, amen.
Yes, I know, yes.
And we have the woman who played
one of the youngest von Trapp girls
in the movie, Brigitta, dialed in.
So let's say hi to Angela
Cartwright, everybody!
(audience cheering and applauding)
Hello!
It's such a cool thing
to have you on the show.
Thank you for joining us.
- Great to be here.
- Awesome, so you were
10 when you filmed it.
So did you think then,
were you just being a kid?
Did you know it was
gonna blow up like that?
Did you think that
movie was gonna be huge?
- No, we had no idea.
We just knew that we were
having a blast doing this movie
and it was just an experience.
But we had no idea that, you know,
it's almost been 60 years now.
And this movie is still going strong.
- I know, you know, you say that,
but literally every
night, my 7-year-old son,
while I'd like draw on his back,
he makes me sing the solfège song.
"Do-Re-Mi."
I have to sing "Do-Re-Mi,"
that whole song, every night,
like, while I scratch his back.
He's seven, and it was over 60 years ago
the film was released.
What a pop culture impact
that movie has had.
So there's a new super deluxe version
of "The Sound of Music"
soundtrack coming out in February.
It features 40 previously
unreleased tracks from the film,
which is so cool.
(audience cheering)
So very cool.
And I'm taking this.
So outta these-
- I mean that's never been done before.
This is just the soundtrack.
And it has all the music from,
you know, all the scenes,
even the parts that we're not singing.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And so nobody's really heard that
except on the movie itself.
So it's very, very special.
It's lovely.
It really is very special.
(audience applauding)
- Wow, that's special.
- Yeah.
- I love the behind-the-scenes
nature of this.
This is so cool.
Like a film that's so
loved by so many families.
That's so cool, to get all of
this now, like later in life.
The super deluxe edition
of "The Sound of Music"
is available on digital
platforms right now, everybody.
And the box set drops February 2nd.
It's available for
pre-order, so reserve a copy.
Thank you so much for joining us.
(audience cheering and applauding)
This is so cool.
I'm liking your post right now.
(bell dings)
And generally at this point in the show,
we give our guests $1,000,
courtesy of our season-long
partner Pilot Pen,
makers of FriXion, the go-to erasable pen
of "The Kelly Clarkson Show."
But I think Angela's
doing all right, right?
She's an actress.
She's been killing it for decades.
She don't need this, so,
she's done well for herself.
So we're gonna give it to one of you.
Does anybody want $1,000?
(audience cheering and applauding)
Well, look in the monitor.
And somebody's face is gonna show up
and that's who's getting the cash.
Let's go!
(audience cheering and applauding)
(upbeat music)
Yes!
(Kelly whooping)
What?
Wait, what's your name?
- I'm Bailey.
- You're Bailey?
- Yes.
- What are you gonna do
with a grand, Bailey?
- I don't know, I think I'm gonna have to
take a trip somewhere because that's just
a crazy amount of money.
- [Kelly] Thank you.
People always say pay bills.
That's nice.
- Nah.
- But have some fun with it.
- [Bailey] Thank you!
- [Kelly] Thank you for coming, Bailey.
- Oh, thank you!
- Congrats on the grand.
And thank you all our guests
this hour, Jason Momoa,
Fantasia Barrino Taylor,
Ruth, Adam Woodworth,
and Rubin Ervin.
Y'all have a great day.
And if it's not, change it.